they're known as Boko Haram brides
forced to marry militant fighters are
now caring for the babies born from rape
try to have sex with me when I refuse
will be beating me when he is tired of
beating me he will now push me down and
press me down and make use of me the
teenagers still barely out of childhood
themselves free may be but outcasts
anywhere we still they will just get
away everybody have known that our
husbands were into killings and now they
feel that if they should stay in the
same area will also one day rise up and
be killing them they're not the only
ones with the rape babies they were held
in the same piece of forest alongside
the chibok schoolgirls taken nearly
three years ago together on even
December's and greet each other and
spend time together with each other the
military crackdown is hurting the terror
group allied to is but they're becoming
more extreme girls not brides are turned
into bombers this 14 year old was caught
three weeks ago her suicide vest hidden
under her hijab her friend blew herself
up here she's saying they were both
taken by Boko Haram and paid just 200
Nara to kill that's about 40 British
pence terror comes cheap when you're
frightened and young there's a very
unfortunate children little girls who
have been involved who have engaged too
many Koreans of this endoscopy apps of
the bop around terrorists so in my view
it's a sheer act of desperation millions
have fled the terror group and are now
living in camps this one in Matagorda
Bay gist and Africa
50,000 people are here they live with
soldiers guarding them the children
fight to get into schools a chance of an
education Behrendt as evil by Boko Haram
[Music]
going to class would invite an attack
from the terrorists before Boko Haram
made me scared to go to school she says
but now we have security I can learn the
brutality of Boko Haram is meted out to
all who resist this is one of their
fighters but when he tried to escape his
disloyalty was severely dealt with they
grabbed us they were three of us all
together they tied us up about man men
help me God first it was unbelievable
I've never felt anything like it in my
life
I thought that we're going to slaughter
us I was struggling and then they cut my
leg off the most vulnerable are
suffering most with Nigeria on the brink
of famine and forecast it will get worse
Alex Crawford Sky News in northern
Nigeria